[Musique]
un soleil sur lequel on nous est pas
compté a amené à Longchamp la foule des
grands jours pour l'événement de la
saison hippique le Grand Prix de Paris
[Musique]
dès le départ après l'arrêt m'a pris la
tête de ses 18 concurrents mais avec ces
3000 mètres le parcours laisse toute
latitude aux émotions
après le moulin l'oracle même devant
château d'Espagne et Prince courageux
entrée de la ligne droite Prince
courageux est apparu en tête du peloton
mais s'ignore comme et la faute d'ouvrir
la corde et le jockey point Slee yanguf
au Sanctus et ses Sanctus déjà vainqueur
du Prix du Jockey Club qui termine avec
une longueur
sa victoire fait tomber une pluie de
millions sur les œufs gagnants bien sûr
il n'y en a pas pour tout le monde
[Musique]
on peut toujours se consoler car la
tranche spéciale du 14 juillet annonce
une nouvelle averse de 66000 lots
représentant un milliard 400 millions
d'anciens francs bien entendu
[Musique]
24 comme 24 Heures du Mans sous ce
chiffre Panhard vient de dévoiler à la
presse ces nouveaux modèles 24C coachs
et 24 CT coupés qui continuent la série
des 17
un système de réglage du volant et des
sièges avant qui permet de réaliser un
poste de pilotage sur mesure et s'ajoute
aux qualités traditionnelles de lapin à
confort freinage économie et très grande
visibilité la roue de secours trouve
place sous le coffre arrière dans un
logement spécial rendez-vous au prochain
salon
c'est sous le signe d'une amitié
franco-marocaine demeurer vivante depuis
l'indépendance que s'est déroulée la
visite du roi du Maroc Hassan II à Paris
et l'un de ses premiers gestes a été de
se recueillir sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu le général de Gaulle fait
exceptionnel avait tenu à être à ses
côtés
[Musique]
c'est cette amitié qui ont évoqué dans
leurs entretiens avec l'avenir de la
coopération entre leur pays les deux
chefs d'État
[Musique]
c'est cette amitié enfin qu'on exalter
les plus hautes personnalités des deux
pays au cours de la réception donnée au
Palais de l'Élysée en l'honneur du roi
rassan II nos deux pays a dit le
souverain marocain marcheront côte à
côte dans un avenir de coopération
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poursuivant son voyage en Allemagne le
président des États-Unis recevait de
Berlin Ouest un accueillant enthousiaste
avec le chancelier de Noël et le
bourgmestre Willy brand il était l'objet
d'une sorte de triomphe à l'américaine
[Applaudissements]
à la porte de Brandebourg masquée du
côté soviétique par 10 minces panneaux
monsieur Kennedy a jeté un coup d’œil
sur le secteur oriental qui a tout
récemment accentué sa séparation par la
création le long du fameux mur d'une
zone interdite de 100 mètres de largeur
[Musique]
et c'est à une foule immense que
Monsieur Kennedy a adressé ses paroles
qui ont produit une grosse sensation
tous les âmes libres d'où qu'il soit son
citoyen de Berlin et moi-même en tant
comme libre je suis fier de dire je suis
berline
ces paroles n'ont pas manqué d'avoir un
écho de l'autre côté de cette barrière
inhumaine où s'est enfermée depuis deux
ans Berlin est dans le but d'arrêter la
fuite vers l'ouest des populations
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de cette barrière dans
l'autre Berlin monsieur Nikita coachov
est arrivé deux jours après le départ du
président américain bon voyage réponse
peut-être mais que l'on explique par
l'anniversaire du président de
l'Allemagne de l'Est monsieur
kruchev a rencontré à Berlin Est les
dirigeants des états communiquent et en
dehors des discussions de doctrine nul
doute qu'il est abordé avec eux le
problème des relations est ouest et
celui de l'Allemagne
dans ce coin des Hautes-Alpes ils ne
sont sans doute pas rares ces chemins ou
rien ne passe sinon parfois un troupeau
mais ce chemin ne mène pas seulement à
la montagne il a pour aboutissement un
village saint Cyris et quel village
voici bientôt 20 ans le dernier habitant
à quitté sa maison pour l'hospice depuis
rien n'a changé les portes bat Thauvin
les murs se désagrègent saint-ciris est
devenu un spectre seul encore presque
intact la mairie qui est à la fois
église et école demeure debout au milieu
de son cimetière envahi par l'herbe
[Musique]
personne ne vient plus prier ici
personne ne vient plus s'asseoir sur ses
bancs pourtant cette commune qui compte
à 80 électeurs a toujours une existence
légale étrange comme une sans le moindre
habitant mais dont la mairie continue à
fonctionner étrange conseil dont cinq
membres sur 9 appartiennent à la même
famille et qui administre un village
mort madame je m'excuse assistant nous a
une séance du conseil municipal de
saint-ciris ou à une réunion de famille
c'est une réunion du conseil municipal
monsieur mais également à une réunion de
famille parce que nous sommes ici c'est
un arbre de la même famille et puis la
minorité de l'autre côté du conseil
municipal nous nous sommes toujours
d'accord quand il s'agit du bien de la
commune
devant cette réunion on peut s'étonner
comment un village abandonné peut-il
encore avoir un conseil municipal
c'est un village à
à 20h sur la commune de Saint-Céré et de
ce fait qui ont le droit de d'être
conseiller municipaux dans cette commune
saint-cylise a été abandonné Monsieur
Pascal 1910 plusieurs propriétaires ont
vendu à l'état c'est à dire aux Eaux et
Forêts et du fait du reboisement et bien
plusieurs propriétés ont dû quitter
encore le pays parce qu'il n'avait plus
assez de surface de pour vivre
voilà saint-ciris la commune la plus
insolite de France une mairie n'est plus
de village un maire n'est pas de
population
saint-ciris qui totalement abandonné
figure toujours sur la liste des
communes de France se survit hors de
toute réalité saint iris ou la commune
fantôme
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
les cérémonies du couronnement du pape
se seront déroulés d'un bout à l'autre
sur le parvis de Saint-Pierre face au
ciel devant la foule des chrétiens
[Musique]
dans la parade traditionnelle qui
rappelle les fastes de la Renaissance Sa
Sainteté Paul VI a gagné l'hôtel dressé
devant la basilique
là le 262E successeur de Saint-Pierre
l'évêque de Rome a célébré la messe du
couronnement en présence des
représentants de 80 nations parmi
lesquels on reconnaissait Monsieur
Georges Pompidou qui représentait la
France le prince Constantin de Grèce
le roi des Belges et la reine Fabiola
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voici l'instinct solennel le
Souverain Pontife reçoit des mains du
cardinal octaviani la tiare 3 couronnes
[Musique]
et au son de toutes les cloches de Rome
aux acclamations de 250 000 personnes le
pape regagne le Vatican un nouveau règne
a commencé
[Musique]
la saison d'athlétisme commence
décidément très bien pour les français
si les choses vont aussi bien pour eux
l'an prochain à Tokyo il reviendront
sûrement à Paris après avoir glané
quelques médailles olympiques mais nous
n'en sommes pas encore là pour le moment
c'est alors performance actuelle que
nous nous intéressons et à celle de
Robert Baugé à Moscou en particulier de
Sarre numéro 7 il pulvérise le record de
France du 10000 mètres de plus de 13
secondes et par surcroît il coiffe le
soviétique Ivanov sur le fil et cela
aussi c'est une performance
quant à Michel JAZY s'est également
Moscou qui la choisi pour ses premiers
grands débuts internationaux sur 5000
mètres
après un début de course extrêmement
prudent Michel JAZY attend le dernier
400 mètres pour démarrer comme les seuls
au monde c'est le faire résultat une
nouvelle victoire et un nouveau record
de France du 5000 mètres
[Musique]
si la visite du général de Gaulle a
bonne s'inscrite aujourd'hui dans la
routine des relations franco-allemandes
elle n'en prend pas moins après la
visite de Monsieur Kennedy une
signification de confiance dans les
destinées du traité récemment ratifié
[Musique]
le chancelier de Noël et ses ministres
au premier plan desquels le futur
chancelier monsieur Errard tenait avec
Monsieur Pompidou et les 5 ministres
qu'il accompagnaient une première séance
de travail qu'on peut presque considérer
comme une séance commune des cabinets
allemands et français déjà un premier
pas a été fait avec la signature d'un
accord qui prévoit des échanges de la
jeunesse des deux pays
à Berla Hestre monsieur kotchafa rendu
visite au président de la République
démocratique allemande monsieur
valteroul bricht en même temps que les
leaders des gouvernements
tchécoslovaques polonais hongrois et
bulgare prétexte les 70 ans de valteroul
Bridge en réalité réunion au sommet des
états d'obédiance communiste seul
manquait à la Réunion le chef du
gouvernement roumain en froid avec
l'URSS décoration et festivités ne
voilent donc qu'un parfaitement la
signification politique de cette
rencontre
[Musique]
nous devons cette année une pensée
particulière à un Français Adolf pegout
pegou fut en quelque sorte un pilote
d'essai des temps héroïques c'est ainsi
qu'il avait expérimenté un système
d'accrochage des avions pour le
décollage et la pontage susceptibles
d'être par la suite utilisé sur les
cuirasses
peggout effectua de la sorte une série
concluante d'un vol et d'accrochage sur
un film
[Musique]
de telles exercices auraient suffis à
lui mériter sa réputation d'un trépidité
mais il fit plus un jour de 1913 il
décola à bord d'un monoplan Blériot pour
exécuter devant une foule médusée les
premiers looping qui est jamais été
tentés on exploit qui compte tenu de
l'époque valait sans doute tous les
exploits accomplis depuis
[Musique]
à terre ce fut du délire ce pionnier du
ciel qui mourut en combat aérien pendant
la grande guerre n'a pas laissé un
souvenir aussi vivace que les lignes
bergs et les Mermoz mais 50 ans après
son exploit il est juste de rendre
hommage à celui que la foule acclamait
alors au côté de Blériot peggout
l'intrépie
[Musique]
4 siècles et demi après la découverte du
continent américain par Christophe
Colomb l'immense forêt amazonienne
demeure encore un champ d'exploration
pour les aventuriers de notre temps
c'est le domaine des étranges tattoo
d'un maître Delon qui évolue sous les
arbres à pain et les bananiers
c'est aussi celui des fourmis géantes
domaine inquiétant que la Colombie
partage avec ses voisins d'Amérique du
Sud
mais la vie tout entière est ailleurs et
essentiellement dans les villes bâtit
tantôt comme Bogota à 2600 mètres dans
la cordillère tantôt au fond des vallées
du passé espagnol la capitale de la
Colombie n'a gardé que quelques rares
balcons quelques églises
[Musique]
c'est pratiquement une ville nouvelle
dont le développement intensif ne cesse
pas elle compte un million 300 000
habitants aujourd'hui pour une nation de
15 millions
[Musique]
et la longueur de la file desireurs
donne la mesure du grouillement de la
cité
celle-ci s'en orgueille de posséder un
aéroport international qui a la
réputation d'être le plus moderne de
l'Amérique latine
[Musique]
le café à sa propre banque à Bogota
banco qui a fêtero c'est qu'il est une
des premières ressources de ce pays
deuxième producteur du monde en valeur
absolue la Colombie et le premier
producteur de café de type léger
la Banque Nationale évoque un autre
record la Colombie et le premier
producteur mondial d'émeraude c'est dans
son sol qu'on a découvert les plus
grosses de ces pierres aussi appréciées
que les diamants
nedeline est une ville de vallée ici au
cours des 50 dernières années les
statues précolombiennes ont vu une
humble bourgade devenir une ville de 650
000 habitants c'est la ville
industrielle de la Colombie 21% de la
production du pays sortent de ces
manufactures
pour s'industrialiser la Colombie à
disposer sur place de cette source
d'énergie par excellence quel est le
pétrole pays de l’heure c'est aussi le
pays de l'or noir que les pompes achève
d'aspirer dans les puits les plus
anciens 8 millions de tonnes par an dont
près de la moitié est absorbé par la
consommation nationale des raffineries
ont poussé au bord de la magdalenia le
grand axe fluvial qui traverse la
Colombie du sud au nord
à l'embouchure du fleuve dans la mer des
Antilles où la température moyenne
atteint 30 degrés Barranquilla
monopolise le commerce colombien vers
l'Europe
[Musique]
ici commence un autre pays avec ses
cactus scandellabre et son climat
méditerranéen la Côte d'Azur de la
Colombie en quelque sorte la plage de
Santa Marta évoque ses paradises
enchanteurs de vacances qui à l'heure du
ski nautique ressemble tous à la Floride
[Musique]
qui par cette côte où les Espagnols font
d'air la carte à gêne des Indes car
hiver tous les envahisseurs et ils
furent nombreux si bien que le plus
éloquent symbole de la cité et cette
statue d'un héros national privé d'une
jambe d'un bras d'un œil
de la tortue n'est pas loin et
Carthagène a subi en attendant celui des
touristes l'assaut quasi permanent des
corsaires les Anglais Grecs et Morgan le
français Pointis
[Musique]
mais on n'a pas de rancune à Carthagène
la flibuste fait toujours recette
[Musique]
14 juillet sur les Champs-Élysées au
milieu de plus de 100000 Parisiens le
général de Gaulle accompagné du Premier
ministre monsieur Pompidou et de
Monsieur Messmer ministre des armées est
venu présider le défilé traditionnel
ce défilé pour lui avait un sens précis
ce défilé c'était l'armée d'une France
dégagée des luttes coloniales
fait derrière les grandes écoles dont
les uniformes évoquent d'autres temps
c'était une armée transformée
reconvertie reformé à la mesure de
l'époque
avec les unités d'élite et les
parachutistes le célèbre premier
régiment de la Légion étrangère qui
s'illustre depuis plus d'un siècle sur
tous les continents avait repris sa
place cette année dans le défilé
mais le sommet de la manifestation
c'était l'apparition pour la première
fois d'une brigade blindée et les mains
majeurs des forces d'intervention
moderne
précédé par les chars à MX de 30 tonnes
qui armeront progressivement les unités
de cet ordre capable d'opérer dans une
atmosphère nucléaire
suivi de chasseurs de chars à missiles
cette formation nouvelle composée de 300
enginseniers de 4000 hommes n'est qu'un
début
en effet le programme de 1959 prévoit la
formation de 6 divisions de choc de
18000 hommes chacune c'est cette armée
nouvelle et pour ainsi dire régénérer
que la foule parisienne a salué en ce 14
juillet l'armée de demain qui devient
l'armée d'aujourd'hui
rarement visite royale leur a causé au
temps de soucis au gouvernement
britannique que celle du roi Paul de
Grèce et de la reine Frédérica à Londres
rarement aussi autant de policiers
auront été mobilisés pour faire
respecter la belle ordonnance du cortège
traditionnel cher au cœur des Londoniens
devant ce déploiement cependant les
manifestants n'ont pas renoncé à
profiter du séjour des souverains grecs
pour réclamer la libération des
prisonniers incarcérées en Grèce depuis
la guerre civile
employant systématiquement la technique
éprouvée qui consiste à s'asseoir et à
rester immobile sur la chaussée ils se
sont heurtés à la police londonienne qui
elle aussi et parfaitement
[Applaudissements]
ôté
[Musique]
Bruxelles à doute pris son aire de
vacances et cependant tous les touristes
qui débarquent sur la magnifique
Grand-Place peuvent comprendre qu'un
graph problème est posé à la Nation
belge celui qui affiche innoceaux
bilingues celui des deux langues et des
deux races flamants et Wallons le
gouvernement avait pensé faire absorber
par la capitale si commune or la
banlieue est flamande d'où le drame
l'opinion flamande exprimons-la par la
voix de Monsieur De Coninck député de
Bruxelles
nous préconisons un statut organique
pour les deux communautés nous nous
opposons avec la plus extrême énergie
contre tout empiètement du territoire
sur le territoire flamand à partir de la
francisation partant de Bruxelles
le fait de réalisme est déjà dans la
dans la fête et permettra dans l'avenir
de préserver la culture flamande qui a
toujours été tenu sous l'étouffoires
l'opinion wallonne le président du
Mouvement populaire wallon Monsieur Léon
défaussé nous l'expose pour nous allons
l'essentiel des critiques que nous
dirigeons contre les projets
linguistiques du gouvernement c'est
qu'il traduisent une volonté délibérée
de flamandisation systématique et
intégrale de l'administration et même de
Bruxelles en général devant une telle
offensive flamingante systématique la
seule réaction de la Wallonie c'est de
réclamer d'exiger son autonomie
politique dans le cadre d'un État
fédéral il est certain en effet à notre
sens que le fédéralisme et la seule
chance la dernière chance de survie d'un
état belge
grave question comme on le voit et qui
depuis quelques années a sensibilisé les
foules des deux côtés faut-il rappeler
ces marches flamandes sur Bruxelles et
ses manifestations qui se terminaient
voici encore quelques mois dans la
violence
la violence n'a pas des armées au cœur
même des discussions actuelles qui tout
de même aboutissaient à une sorte
d'accord une bombe détériorer la colonne
du Congrès symbole de la Charte de la
Belgique indépendante
[Musique]
et quand disent les Bruxellois
alors tout ce qui s'est passé ici en
Belgique
d'autant plus que l'unité du pays est en
jeu je trouve que les Français les
c'est-à-dire les Belges l'expression
française et le Belge expressions
flamand doit pouvoir s'entendre
nous sommes tous belges au fond et bien
monsieur moi je savais moi je suis
contre je suis un peu contre tout dans
le fond mais je trouve que le Belge ça a
été un Belge le Belge c'est un belge par
conséquent c'est anormal zéro bientôt
une barrière une barrière à Lost coupant
et là on vous demandera votre carte
d'identité on a dit dans le temps ce
qu'il donne Pringles savoir si on savait
le dire en flamand et à ce moment-là si
vous saviez pas le dire on vous coupez
la gorge et bien moi je suis pas
d'accord avec c'est parce que moi je
veux aller à la côte à la mer la mer ça
appartient à tout le monde les Ardennes
c'est bien mais moi j'aime pas les
Ardennes de toute façon nous sommes des
Belges qu'on soit wallon qu'on soit
bruxellois ou qu'on soit flamand c'est
la même chose somme de belles chaussures
c'est tout un seul Belge contemple cette
affrontement avec sérénité le
Manneken-Pis mais il n'en pense pas
moins
de tous les champions se sont bien les
nageurs qui ont choisi le sport le plus
agréable surtout pendant la canicule et
là au Grand Prix de Paris malgré la
chaleur esprits s'en donne à cœur joie
dans le 129 livres Alain godwallès une
fois de plus est encore le meilleur 55
secondes c'est loin du record du monde
mais qui c'est
dans l'entend debout si la petite
Christine Caron continue de nager comme
elle le fait depuis le début de la
saison
passage qui a
à peine d'une super
chance celui du 100 mètres d'eau en une
minute 9 secondes 6/10 et celui du 200
mètres d'eau en deux minutes 33 secondes
5/10
[Applaudissements]
et enfin prodige
[Musique]
et Saint-Bernard en témoigne alors
manières avec une certaine turbulence
d'ailleurs cette année c'est dans les
Alpes
[Musique]
que les Pyrénées n'avaient été qu'un
hors-d'oeuvre une promenade en quelque
sorte sauf pour le beige van loy pris à
froid dans la montagne en revanche les
Alpes n'ont pardonné aucune défaillance
et Dieu sait s'il y en a eu
la plus dramatique celle de l'un des
favoris Raymond Poulidor
sans pouliantesse numéro 41 le roi de la
montagne est encore maillot jaune avant
l'arrivée à Chamonix les Jacques
Anquetil qui est vraiment le Superman de
ce tour 1963 fait à cette occasion
la grande étape des Alpes à Chamonix
c'est là qu'il a remporté le Tour de
France cette année il n'a pas eu besoin
de l'étape contre l'âme
la suite n'est plus qu'une formalité et
lorsque le peloton est en vue de la
capitale française quelques jours plus
tard ce sont les centaines de milliers
de Parisiens qui ovacionnent Jacques
Anquetil vainqueur pour la quatrième
fois du Tour de France
méritait quand même une récompense
pour Jacques Anquetil c'est le record
des victoires jamais personne avant lui
même Louison Bobet n'avait fait mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Saint Firmin c'est pour les habitants
de Pampelune 8 jours de folie collective
la grande vedette de cette fête
interminable c'est le taureau c'est lui
qui fait naître l'hystérie chez tous
ceux qui rêvent de la gloire des arènes
et la peur panique chez les autres
[Musique]
sur la Plaza c'est là que grouille tous
les matador du dimanche 13 à toutes les
folies pour approcher le taureau
[Applaudissements]
dans cette foule déchaînées le taureau
lui ne sait plus où donner de la corne
il n'empêche qu'il restera le roi de la
reine jusqu'à l'heure de la corrida
[Musique]
un miracle cette année il n'y a pas eu
de mort et pourtant les apprentis torero
n'ont rien fait pour éviter le pire
Christine Caron qui qui pour les intimes
l'enfant prodige de la natation
française est un véritable petit poisson
remarquez bien qu'il lui arrive quand
même de sortir de l'eau de temps en
temps quand elle n'est pas dans une
piscine elle écoute Richard Anthony ou
bien elle dévore car elle a un appétit
d'ogre elle suit aussi des cours au
lycée mais là elle est beaucoup moins
douée mais revenons à Kiki petit poisson
c'est sous la direction de son
entraîneur Suzanne berliou quel parcourt
ainsi 1000 km par an à Lana
après avoir battu des records d'Europe
en âge sur le dos c'est sa spécialité
Christine Caron s'est offert de
nouvelles journées de gloire à
l'occasion des championnats de France au
stade Georges Vallerey à Paris
les grandes n'ont pas pu lui résister et
Kiki le bébé nageur qui vient à peine
d'avoir 15 ans a remporté en quelques
gracieux battements le titre du 100 m et
du 200 mètres d'eau
[Musique]
à Moscou c'est un temps de bonne humeur
qui a accueilli les délégués
britanniques et américains lors d'un
Cham et Monsieur Havre à la conférence
des trois sur l'arrêt des expériences
nucléaires et thèse dès le début la
manifestation d'une volonté générale
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un Turquie que son premier voyage
officiel à l'étranger a conduit le
Premier ministre monsieur Pompidou avec
pour compagnon un jeune étudiant sans
moyen qui rêvait de faire là-bas un
voyage d'études tous deux le Premier
ministre et l'étudiant ont pu en
survolant Istanbul et piloquée sur la
Vieille Capitale battue des eaux tièdes
du Bosphore ou du pont de Galata à la
tour de Léandre s'est déroulée au long
de 1500 ans une partie de l'histoire du
monde
Istanbul n'est plus capital
Istanbul cependant n'a pas oublié
qu'elle fut Byzance et qu'elle fut
Constantinople elle garde avec ses dômes
et ses minarets avec le grouillement de
la Corne d'Or avec la couronne écroulée
des remparts qui résistèrent à combien
d'assaut cette revanche de demeurer
l'une des villes du monde les plus
fabuleuses et les plus poignants
[Musique]
elle reste faisant ornement des canons
qui bâtirent ces murs miraculeusement
légendaire dans le décor des mille et
une nuits dressées par ces mosquées dont
certaines furent des églises et
l'immense des dalles de son bazar où
l'on trouve tout
car ces réalités concrètes n'ont rien
aux rêves de cette ville unique où s'est
endormie tour à tour la puissance de
l'empire romain la gloire de Byzance et
la force de l'État haussement lit qui
devint avant 1914 l'homme malade de
l'Europe
c'est sur une autre Turquie qui a
débarqué monsieur George Pompidou le
chef du gouvernement turc monsieur
ismetinonu l'a accueilli à Ankara qui a
succédé comme capitale à Constantinople
et où le président de la République le
Général gursell devait entamer avec lui
un large tour d'horizon sur l'avenir
franco-turc
Ankara est le triomphe de l'imagination
créatrice
[Musique]
digne et ses avenues où les automobiles
croisent des attelages d'un autre temps
étaient tirés du néant il fut un effort
pour le concevoir la volonté de Kemal
Atatürk produisit ce miracle elle
enfitte un autre tirer un peuple moderne
d'une population illettrée s'attaquant
d'abord à l'esprit à ta turc remplaça
l'écriture sous fit par l'écriture
romaine de ce fait la langue turque a
fait de nombreux emprunts phonétiquement
on s'y retrouve mais on a des surprises
[Musique]
il n'en n'est pas moins que l'appétit du
savoir a conquis la Turquie l'école
compte parmi les grandes batailles qu'a
livrées et gagner le nouvel état dans
les villages les classes enfantines
dessinent dans l'air pour mieux les
apprendre les lettres de l'alphabet
et à l'université d'un carat des
fonctionnaires des commerçants des
employés suivent le soir les classes de
français que cherche-t-il ces adultes
dont la moitié au moins son chef de
famille le guide le plus sûr dans la vie
c'est la science leur a répondu à ta
turc
cette Turquie a dans le monde son rôle à
jouer son importance tient à ce poste
dangereux qu'elle occupe à la limite des
deux mondes gardiennes des détroits elle
assure la permanence d'un équilibre
construit par cinq siècles de vie
européenne sentinelle du monde libre
elle monte la garde sur les flancs
glacées du Caucase comme aux lisière des
Balkans c'est 600 000 soldats instruits
et armés par l'Occident compostent une
armée que les experts tiennent pour
l'une des forces les plus authentiques
de l'OTAN
ami depuis le 16e siècle partenaire
aujourd'hui au sein de l'OTAN demain au
sein du marché commun la France et la
Turquie se rapprochent à nouveau
aujourd'hui
c'est sans doute ce qu'a voulu
manifester monsieur Pompidou par sa
visite au pays data turc et par le geste
d'hommage qu'il a fait à la tête de la
délégation française au pied du
monumental tombeau ou repose tout près
de son rêve réalisé l'homme génial qui
est le seul lien ici entre le passé et
le présent
pour ses voyageurs décidaient mais à la
Bourse plate que sont les autostoppeurs
la saison en France se révèle difficile
la presse a évoqué de sombres histoires
de malheureuses perspective bref
l'autostop n'a plus la cote on a cité le
cas d'automobiliste serviable si l'on
peut dire jusqu'au bout des ondes et
l'excès en tout est un défaut
nul ne sait après tout ou commence la
route de Buenos Aires
on a cité aussi le cas de braves
auto-stoppeur dont les bagages ont été
complaisamment prise en charge et qui ne
les ont jamais revu
on a cité enfin le cas d'auto-stoppeur à
la main trop l'est pour qui l'autostop
n'était que l'alibi de sombre projet
pour tout dire la méfiance règne et la
concurrence n'en est que plus redoutable
pour ceux qui restent en dépit de tout
fidèle à l'autostop l'organisation la
plus classique qui fait appel à des
techniques éprouvées reste encore
payantes il faut bien le dire
[Musique]
mais l'auto-stoppeur mâle s'il est
isolés ne devra-t-il pas désormais faire
appel à toutes les ressources d'une
garde-robe très étudiée les statistiques
attestent qu'une automobile s'arrêtent
plus facilement devant une jupe mais
elle ne parle que de la jupe
reste la soutane du prêtre qui demeure
avec l'abilité une valeur sûre de
l'auto-stop
[Musique]
à ce point de raffinement autant adopter
la tenue de gendarme l'arrêt est
garantie
[Musique]
et l'automobiliste se sent même tout
naturellement porté à la prévenance
reste encore à savoir où tout cela vous
conduira
[Musique]
qui s'appelait autrefois husqbe était
hier encore une grande ville de 250 000
habitants capitale de la Macédoine elle
s'était magnifiquement développée depuis
la fin de la guerre ajoutant à ses
anciens édifices des faubourgs de
construction neuve mais on ne reverra
plus à scopier ce visage d'hier un
tremblement de terre la changer en un
désert de ruine
[Musique]
de la gare ouverte comme un cratère dont
l'horloge marque l'heure de la
catastrophe jusqu'au fond des banlieues
scopie et maintenant détruite ou
endommagée à
80%. à l'aube naissance une secousse qui
durera 20 secondes secoue la ville deux
nouvelles secousses quoiquent plus
faibles la chair les plus grands
édifices et des centaines d'immeubles de
3 à 4 étages ne sont plus maintenant que
des amas de décombres et dessous reste
encore sans doute des centaines de
victimes
[Musique]
les victimes à l'heure actuelle on a
retiré des décombres près d'un millier
de morts on a dénombré plus de 2000
blessés mais les ruines gardent
probablement encore des emmurer vivant
ou mort
[Musique]
devant l'hôtel macédonien les voitures
écrasées plus de 300 touristes
résidaient ici parmi lesquels plusieurs
familles françaises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le maréchal Tito est venu se rendre
compte de l'ampleur du désastre et
prendre sur place les mesures utiles car
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont maintenant sans abri et démunis de
tout
[Musique]
mais cette population n'aspire qu'à fuir
le lieu du cynisme le maréchal Tito a
décrété l'évacuation générale car la
menace des terribles séquelles de toutes
les catastrophes paient sur scopie
manque d'eau manque de vivre manque de
médicaments et par dessus tout l'horreur
possible du typhus
[Musique]
concert de contentement général que
Messieurs hariman délégué des États-Unis
Andreï gromico ministre des Affaires
étrangères soviétiques et lors d'un Cham
de légué britannique on part a fait au
Kremlin l'accord sur la raie partiel des
expériences nucléaires sur ce problème
la France quatrième puissance nucléaire
aujourd'hui a marqué sa position par la
voie du général de Gaulle
nous participons
à la joie que le président Kennedy si
localement exprimé avant-hier au sujet
de cet événement
mais sans méconnaître encore une fois
que cet accord de Moscou
puisse désobliger personne et en tout
cas pas nous
il faut bien voir
qu'il ne change rien
à la terrible menace
que les armements nucléaires
des deux rivaux
font peser sur le monde
en particulier sur ce des peuples qui en
sont dépourvus
c'est pourquoi
l'accord de Moscou je le dis franchement
au point de vue totale et pratique pour
le monde
n'a pas n'accune importance réduite dans
ces conditions continuent le général de
Gaulle la France ne sera pas détournée
de se doter des moyens atomiques
cependant elle serait disposée à
proposer aux trois autres puissances
atomiques certaines mesures effectives
et pratiques de désarmement
ce qui s'est passé à Moscou ne fait que
la confirmer dans cette attention
et elle compte avant la fin de cette
année
invité les États intéressés
à étudier en commun avec elle ce
problème essentiel
avant
que peut-être
il souhaite venu insolubles à son tour
progression industrielle française les
trois centrales nucléaires que
l'électricité de France édifie sur les
bords de la Loire à Chinon ont reçu la
visite de Monsieur Georges Pompidou dans
trois ans c'est 3 centrales edf-1 et des
F2 et EDF 3 totaliseront une puissance
de 600000 kW cette visite constituait si
l'on peut dire le morceau de choix du
voyage d'information que le premier
ministre vient de faire un Touraine et
qui devait lui donner l'occasion de
rencontrer à Montlouis son prédécesseur
à Matignon Monsieur Michel Debré autour
d'un verre de vin de la Loire bien
entendu
[Musique]
prestation de la participation française
à la conquête de l'espace les
techniciens du centre de lancement des
îles du levain ont procédé au tir de
deux fusées Bérénice dans le but de
mesurer l'échauffement consécutif à une
rentrée dans l'atmosphère à la vitesse
de match 14
les fusils Bérénice ne sont autre que
des laboratoires volants capables de
transporter aux vitesses et aux
altitudes désirées le matériel a
expérimenté elles sont en quelque sorte
le banc d'essai préparatoires au futur
tentatives spatiales français
nouveau succès technique à l'actif de
l'hélicoptère lourd Super Frelon à
triple turbine qui s'était fait
remarquer au salon du Bourget pour sa
capacité de transport de charges de 4
tonnes et qui vient de battre coup sur
coup trois records du monde de vitesse
avec le record d'altitude détenu depuis
5 ans par une Alouette 2 la construction
française détient donc maintenant les
deux principales séries de records pour
hélicoptère
il a suffit d'une étincelle pour
réconcilier les deux frères ennemis de
l'athlétisme français Michel jasy et
Michel Bernard c'était un ciel c'est
vadou leur cadet le troisième homme qui
a su créer par des paroles amicales
résultat une finale du 1500 mètres au
championnat de France comme en enverra
sans doute jamais plus les deux Michels
ont pris leur responsabilité
l'un après l'autre l'un relayant l'autre
ils ont pensé sur la piste sans chercher
à savoir qui elle les gagne
enfin Zazie et son démarrage éclair et
tout de même Bernard accroché à quelques
mètres derrière lui un spectacle
inoubliable qui vote à jaser un record
d'Europe et à Bernard la deuxième
meilleure performance mondiale de
l'année mais vadou le réconciliateur qui
termine 3e sera sans doute de mal
meilleur de tous
[Musique]
les bolides de grands-papa ont encore
bon pied bon œil et ça part au quart de
tour comme au 24 Heures du Mans enfin
presque
c'est dans la patrie de Rabelais à
contre que se déroule cette épreuve
d'endurance pour Tophe des toft qui ont
la coquetterie de rouler plein gaz
pendant 3 heures d'affilée c'est assez
joli pour des ancêtres
et quand on va trop vite voilà ce qui
arrive
décidément le public est toujours sans
pitié
étage là on respecte rien à croire que
c'est bien barre des retombée en enfance
et tout y est dans cette course est
comme au 24 Heures du Mans il y a du
suspense et des frissons dans les rangs
des spectateurs de quoi vous donner des
sueurs froides
[Musique]
quelques pour les concurrents en sueurs
l'arrêt buvette est obligatoire on
appelle cela faire le plein
il en est ainsi pendant trois heures au
bout desquelles les voitures terminent
quand même sont les chapeaux de roue
gagnez et à l'année prochaine
[Musique]